we're asked to rotate the line segment
negative 90 degrees around the origin so
this is our line segment we want to
rotate it around the origin so let's use
our rotate tool
so
let's define our point of rotation so
we're going to rotate around the origin
so that's why i put it there and i'm
going to rotate it negative 90 degrees
so i'm going to rotate it in this
direction so let's see if i can pull
this off so
so negative
so actually let me undo what i just did
let me get my rotate tool back here so
negative 90 degrees so these arrows
right over here right now they're
straddling the x-axis if i rotate
negative 90 degrees these arrows this
double-headed curvy arrow should
straddle should exactly straddle the
negative y-axis so let's do make sure i
do that so
the negative y axis there we go so i've
rotated this line segment negative 90
degrees about the origin now we got to
answer some questions when a line
segment is rotated the image created is
a well it's of course a line segment we
know this is true because the rotated
image has two endpoints the rotated
image is the same length as the original
image yeah we haven't changed the length
of this we just rotated it around this
dot